there's a lot of people out there whose
job it is to be offended for other
people it's like hey these are opinions
people disagree with like hey United
States everybody comedian Adam Corolla
hosts the most downloaded podcast
in the world which might be why he's
target number one and lawsuit claiming
that all podcasters are in violation of
intellectual property law because the
very act of archiving recorded audio on
the Internet is patented companies who
make most of their money from these
sorts of lawsuits are often called
patent trolls and while most people fold
up and settle with the trolls
Carola is fighting back and says the
future of podcasting is at stake we met
up with Corolla at his Glendale studio
and warehouse to talk about his fight
against the patent trolls his new book
president me his personal politics and
his recent run-ins with various media
outlets that he says have tried to
ambush him Adam thank you very much for
talking to us
thanks for being here Zach here at a
reason TV we've covered the patent troll
issue in the past and usually what
happens is people just settle with them
because they have so much leverage it's
so expensive to even go to court they're
in some place in Texas yet you have
taken a stand and you are fighting back
why why are you fighting back against
the patent trolls well I'm a hero I mean
I mean I mean I guess that sort of is
overstating the obvious but other than
that well if you view things everything
really give us much of a choice they
asked for three million dollars which
seems like a lot and so why wouldn't we
fight back and then we started to kind
of think about it that we were just sort
of number one on their shakedown list
and I'm assuming they just get to
everyone who was in the top 1000 on
iTunes eventually in in the podcasting
world so we sort of felt like well it'd
be nice for our podcasting brothers not
to give them X amount of dollars because
our assumption is since these guys are
just as sort of
they're not in it for the sport they're
not in it for justice they're there it's
a business for them pure and simple like
you know sometimes people are like
aren't you angry at them and I'm like
who's them so it's like are you it's
like being angry at the government for
collecting taxes like that that that's
what they do that's what they do you
know they're a bunch of lawyers they get
together they buy patents they sue
people they make money so I'm assuming
that if we settled up for with them that
they would just go after everybody who
did a podcast and demand that they
settle up with them as well and since
nobody could afford the 1.5 million
dollars it would cost to fight it in
court and whatever part of Texas it
eastern Texas had ended up in then
they'd have no choice so it's a kind of
a I don't know it's like when they take
hostages and when terrorists take
hostages if if you start negotiating
with them then they start kidnapping
more camera crews so we just figured
let's save the next camera crew and
we'll take the duct tape and a zip ties
and well we will rally the community the
podcasting community and we'll get them
to rally their fans and we'll start this
fund to save podcasting and that's what
we've done and I understand you made a
recent trip to Washington DC to try to
get some change done to because you're
talking about a system it's a system
that is broken how did that trip go for
you it was awesome I think it was
Wednesday at noon I was in one of the
congressional buildings talking to a
group of very dapper young people
telling them my story and about why it
was important that we had some reform on
these I know I said reform where I hid a
weird syllable we had we needed some
reform on this whole patent rolling we
need some legislation on this and it was
inspiring I was rousing there were tears
there was laughter there was applause
and then more tears and then I got in a
car and I started driving for Richmond
Virginia where I had to do a show that
night I got a call an hour later that's
at
he from Vermont shot it down oh great so
it by it by the way gave me renewed
belief in the system and how one man
could make a difference oh wait a minute
it's a total waste of time
complete another waste of time because
Lahey the Democrats even though this is
a bipartisan thing or just in the back
pocket of the trial lawyers association
and and the college whatever and
probably Big Pharma and but but he did
because he's a hero cuz ladies a hero
did he did explain that this was very
important because you know how about you
know that all those things are super
important that you're not gonna get to
for yourself yeah you know how it is
like when a doctor says hey this is
really important you go right I'll see
any year right anything super important
like your mechanic goes hey man to give
you these breaks fix it's really
important you go alright I'll see you
about 2016 yeah like I'm great I mean
it's a great emotional victory that he
thinks it's so important that we should
do nothing about it
but at least he's a hero because he did
explain how important it was yeah it
must feel good as she's crushing this
bill he's gone but don't worry it will
be back and I'll crush it again just
give it another year last time we talked
to you you we talked a little about
fixing LA and what you would do or what
we could do once we got via Ragosa out
of there and a viewer ghost is gone now
you have a book out called president me
you've been doing the Washington DC
circuit so what would president Corolla
administration look like what what are
the priorities there that's important to
you well first off I was wrong about
verrucosa he will be missed
I mean there's a void oh no wait about
no one cares horrible I carefully he's
gonna run for governor Wow what's his
platform I'm gonna be like hey I [ __ ]
up LA now let's see what I can do for
California like drove LA into the ground
now you're just gonna drive all of
California into the ocean like based on
your what yeah you're what la for me for
for a place that that is it's where
tax at the rate I mean there can be no
less bang for your buck than LA in terms
of like normally if you're gonna get
taxed at this rate your garbage gets
picked up or the cops show up when you
call them and little things like that
walk on the sidewalks for instance yeah
this this town if you travel around the
countries I do
this town is trashy I mean it's it's
there's graffiti everywhere there's
garbage everywhere there are weeds
springing up through the sidewalks and
the cracks by the side like if you just
drive down the freeway it's covered
garbage and weeds and you know the thing
that's funny
we got barbed wire around the freeway
signs I've traveled I don't think they
have that in Beirut I really don't like
I've been in the hubs of Detroit and
I've been south side of Philly like I've
been everywhere I haven't seen razor
wire around the freeway signs that's one
of those gut-check moments for a city
like that's one of those you know in the
movies where the drunken dad is spanking
his kid and he does that and he looks up
and he sees himself in the mirror you
know and he he knows that and he looks
at the whiskey bottle and he starts
hugging his kid and crying at some point
when we're putting the razor wire up
around the freeway science there's got
to be a point where the citizens of Los
Angeles look at the razor wire and go
what the [ __ ] is going on what are we
doing here why isn't that happened yet
what do you think why hasn't there been
an uprising against whatever's going on
here
well eight years of here we go so it's
not gonna help anything get done right
cuz he's just bang and Telemundo
reporter so he's not I don't think he's
in town or if he is he's partying with
partying with Charlie Sheen in Mexico
like he's not he doesn't maybe not know
about the freeway signs I don't know he
probably doesn't try out our helicopter
man he's a busy man yeah somebody's got
to fail that bar that bar is not gonna
fail itself
somebody's got to fail for it fail that
bar so you know fear ago says yeah
picking up that I don't know but that's
my plan
for my platform is literally just stand
on a platform under a freeway sign on
the 101 and go behold we have race or Y
around our signs
yea and behold I'm getting taxed at a
forty percent right so might maybe
there's one or the other
sure I either want to be taxed at 40%
and have waterlilies around the freeway
sign or I want to be taxed at 25% and
you can use all the barbwire you want
you can make it look like escape from LA
which by the way they didn't think of
that and escape from LA they didn't have
it a good enough crystal ball on the
apocalyptic future of LA to think well
let's put barbed wire around the freeway
science you know you take a certain
level of flak from your some fellow
comedians and your and the media for
some of these criticisms of government
or government officials that you level
but I mean you have your own studio here
you have kind of your own Empire has
that liberated you in a way and do you
think there's leave now I'm sorry all of
you be off sorry he has a liberating for
you and do you think there's other
public figures or other celebrities who
are going to discover this and there's
gonna be more people saying the kind of
things you're saying I don't know if
they're gonna say whatever it is I say
or have been saying I do know that
comedians hate being censored and people
that share their opinion hate being
censored and then they hate to have to
do the fake apology which they have to
do the reason they don't mean the
apology is a they're being forced to
apologize by Viacom or the network or
CBS or whatever whoever owns them who's
getting pressure from some group which
is really just one guy sitting in a
dad's office somewhere but they don't
want to apologize for jokes that they
made because there were jokes or at
least opinions and I I don't know why we
look at this as progress that people
give their opinions and then apologize I
said they give their opinions apologize
and it's like hey these are opinions
people disagree with like hey United
States everybody we're just one big pile
hist or
perkily of opinions that people
disagreed with and that's fine you get
to disagree with those opinions but you
pressuring the person to make a fake
apology over whatever it is he said that
got your panties in a bunch even though
your panties weren't really in a bunch
there's a lot of chat there's a lot of
people out there whose job it is to be
offended for other people it's not
really them they're offended for the
fill-in-the-blank community right but
they're not they don't care themselves
yeah it's a little cottage industry yeah
planers there's this whole outraged
industry and I mean you've actually
recently called out a couple media
outlets for you said trying to kind of
ambush you you go about NPR salon.com
why do you think they're doing this why
do you think you're such a target for
them there's not a lot of people who
disagree with them who are willing to
even talk to them anymore because of the
ambush nature of what they do now they
get you know they're very conversational
they bring up stuff and then they print
these sort of sensational headlines and
they do it out of context and it's it's
it's sort of nothing in it for the
person who's being interviewed by
salon.com anymore because all they're
gonna do is try to make you look like a
bigoted sexist xenophobic whatever you
know in whatever article they're
printing so why even do it I just do it
because I don't I don't care for the
most part but even for me it used to be
that I would do these interviews with
these people they would ask these semi
leading questions you know they'd set
you up who's funnier men or women you
know and you just give your answer men
and then it's okay now they're off and
running now they're setting it up like
when I did NPR in New York they had a
clip from my podcast of me and Jo koy to
roll into you know now it's turning into
like interventions you know like hey
listen to this tell me what you think
that by the way that five years ago it
didn't exist right you could sit down
with whoever you agreed with or whoever
you disagreed with but they didn't play
you a tape or if they played if they
played a bid or a recording
a snippet a trailer whatever of you it
was a funny bit from his upcoming movie
a funny bit from his upcoming sitcom or
book a stiff it from the book it wasn't
gotcha so I go into NPR they play this
gotcha moment with me and Jo koy except
for they're not smart enough to do their
research and realize that that's not me
doing chokeboys voice that's Jo koy
who's an Asian American comedian he's
doing all the talking and making fun of
the asian-american stereotype I'm
laughing he's talking they think it's me
doing a Jackie Chan voice they're doing
the gotcha moment I say you know thanks
a lot for the ambush fellas but you got
the wrong guy cuz that guy's not me and
he's Asian what I told him the guy was
doing the voice was Asian they're like
well that helps like they're still not
done being they're still not done with
their righteous indignation about
something they don't give a [ __ ] about
let's reframe this but at least I'm that
much closer to the light they screwed up
by the way I did this interview over two
weeks ago they've not aired it yet gee
what well some book came out three weeks
ago
why aren't you airing your interview
with me where I call you out several
times on your attempts to ambush me
along these same lines a lot of people
try to classify you as right-wing or
conservative you know we're a
libertarian outlet so our ears kind of
perk up when you talk about you know
cutting taxes or war on drugs or gay
marriage but you seem to kind of reject
a lot of the labels how do you define
yourself politically and in it I don't
you know you know for me it's it's a
mostly libertarian it's just a you bring
up the topic I'll give you the answer
and then once you get enough of those
answers you'll go okay here's what we
have it's a sort of are you an alcoholic
and then you go do you feel like you
need a couple of cocktails to enjoy
yourself in a social environment yes
if you drink when you're happy yes you
drink you're unhappy yes you feel above
you know you check out
boxes and then at the end you got dr.
dugong mm-hmm
so for me I think if you said you know
would you like the lower taxes yes you
would you are you okay with guys having
a pot plant in their backyard yes would
you like government smaller yes I think
when you're done with many of these
questions you proudly end up with
libertarian and I mean the libertarian
alcoholic overlap is pretty high too so
we all that's right I'm I hope I was
clear yes Adam thank you very much for
talking to us appreciate it my pleasure
Zach for reason TV I'm Zach